There's a mathematical order inherent in our universe.
Take a look at this river.
If we measure the length of it and divide by the direct route from the start to
the end,
we'll get [inaudible] or Ben Denas.
We found that the average tenure [inaudible] of every single river in the world
is pie.
The same mathematical constant use to calculate the mass of an electron and the
gentle breathing of a baby helps define how bendy all rivers are.
It's digits never end and never show a pattern,
but they can't possibly be random because they represent the inherent order of
so many things in nature.
At a smaller scale,
we can observe that this drop of water is a liquid,
but depending on how the molecules are arranged,
it could also be a solid or a gas.
Only if it's liquid though,
is it considered wet?
Not all water is wet.
It's this specific arrangement of molecules caused by surface tension that gives
it the emergent property of wetness.
If we were to arrange these water droplets together in a certain way,
we could get a waterfall.
All waterfalls across the world fall at the same speed because they are all
subject to the same acceleration gravity that Nabi or stokes equation describes
how all fluids like the water and this waterfall,
we'll move and behave and it also explains everything from how blood flows in
our body to how we can best simulate water.
In video games.
We can understand the order of the universe by studying the patterns that emerge
from it.
Even something as seemingly random as the shape of a tree's branches has
ordered,
the main trunk of a tree will grow until it produces a branch which has two
growth points and each stem ranches into to this pattern is repeated for every
new stem.
We can model this using the FIBONACCI sequence.
Each successive number is the sum of the previous two and the average ratio of
every two consecutive terms in the sequence gives us a famous constant called
the golden ratio.
We can find examples of the golden ratio everywhere in nature,
the seed pods of a pine cone or a spiral pattern.
If we measure the angle offset between a leaf on a plant stem and the one below
it,
we'll find the average value uses the golden ratio.
It's even present in the formation of waves in the ocean.
This mathematical order applies to mammals as well.
What makes something alive or dead?
The difference between a living bird and a dead one isn't that we're adding some
secret life juice to it.
It's state depends on the specific pattern of its molecules.
Many birds use celestial objects like the sun or stars to navigate their flight
path,
and this requires some trig in the metric calculations,
but it's not that they're calculating these things consciously.
Animals simply do what comes natural to them.
Millions of years of natural selection helped equip them with the capabilities
to survive in their evolutionary niche birds or solving a trigonometry problem.
In the same way a waterfall solves the Navi or stokes equation or a dog salts
object location using visual and chemical signals.
Mathematics is just the language that helps us interpret all this activity.
So the question is,
can math also help us understand how our own brains work?
Can we quantify the feeling of meeting someone special for the first time?
Uh,
what's been your favorite trips?
Oh yeah.
Or the feelings you get when you spend time with them.
Consciousness is a mathematical patterns when information is being processed
governed by a set of patterns like those found in the branches of a tree or the
fluid dynamics of a waterfall.
The way it feels is consciousness.
It's a beautiful emergent phenomenon arising only when molecules are arranged in
a certain pattern.
Just like how wetness arises.
Only one water molecules are arranged in a certain pattern.
Math gives us a framework to reason about what the order behind these patterns
could be and we can use beauty,
the beauty that's all around us as our torch in this journey.
One that we hold up and follow with the belief that eventually it might just
lead us to truth.
Hello world gets to Raj.
I'm here in Portland,
Oregon,
just hiking.
I hope you guys like the video.
The winner of the coding challenge from the last video is Michelle botcher bad
ass of the week and the runner up is set to ear.
No coding.
Challenge this video,
relax,
take a breather and happy holidays to you and everybody you love for now,
I've got to go hike up to a waterfall,
so thanks for watching.